hey there everybody today we're going to
wait
something something's not right here do
i have spots
okay so um took some phone calls and a
little
witchery to get that sorted but i think
we're good now
something's not right here or you know
at least i'm where i'm supposed to be
which
that's all i really care about you know
what's been on my mind
for the last month and a bit body swaps
some of you might have guessed that
wonder woman 1984 and the uh
kerfuffle over how the character of
steve trevor was brought back
to life is what got me thinking about
all this and while
that is what kicked this whole thought
process off
body swapping is a pretty well-worn
trope
both film and television it's been
around for a while
the original freaky friday from 1976 can
probably be credited with popularizing
the concept
but it goes back as far as at least 1830
in written works and probably even
further back in
folklore and fairy stories yet
in all that time i've personally never
seen a body swap
film or tv show spark the kind of
heated conversation that wonder woman
1984 did
and i found myself thinking
about that quite a bit and really
wondering
about the ethical questions that these
sorts of stories almost always ignore
and also how basically every body swap
story before this
got away with it while wonder woman
didn't
now before we get too far into the weeds
on this let me be very clear
this isn't meant to be taken all that
seriously i am not trying to ruin
anyone's favorite piece of entertainment
i'm not here to tell you that you cannot
ethically watch freaky friday or trick
third or your name i just find it
interesting to ask the questions that
these stories
really don't want you asking
questions about consent bodily autonomy
endangerment defamation fraud and
yes even rape so if applying that kind
of lens to what is
usually meant to be a very silly trope
nearly always employed for
harmless fun then you know maybe this
isn't the video for you
that out of the way how about we define
our terms a little bit
one of the nice things about body
swapping is that the name of the trope
is almost all you need to know as far as
explanation goes
the uh oh oh boy um
the mind soul
uh let's go with consciousness so that
thing of two people gets switched and
they find themselves in each other's
bodies
hijinks to follow the mechanisms for the
switch
will vary it's usually fantastical or
supernatural in nature there are
technological justifications sometimes
but they're not nearly as common
sometimes these events take place in an
already fantastical setting like
buffy the vampire slayer gravity falls
farscape but the swap can also be a
single fantastical element in an
otherwise realistically grounded story
as in freaky friday the hot chick and
the change up
i suspect that some of you might have
tilted your heads
when i said that wonder woman 1984 got
me thinking about all this cause that
wasn't really a clean body swap
steve didn't have a body anymore he was
dead
so yes he takes over another man's body
but we don't know what happened to the
other guy's consciousness during that
stretch of time
and steve didn't have a body for it to
be in
if you're thinking that sounds more like
possession
well you are technically correct the
best kind of correct
but the actual results of this shares
more features with body swap stories
than
your standard possession story the thing
about possession is that it's nearly
always malevolent
and instigated by the possessor it's
almost never an accident whereas body
swaps are most commonly involuntary in
some way either by being a complete
accident
or an unintended consequence of
something else there are exceptions and
i'll tackle a few of those but
my point is regardless of the logistics
steve's presence
in this man's body raises the same kinds
of ethical questions that any body swap
story does
so i'm still going to reference it
across this video there are also some
odd body swap
adjacent tropes such as the time jump
self swap
where someone's consciousness is left
forward or
back in time to possess their own older
or younger self think
x-men days of future past or 13 going
off 30.
i won't be including those in this
conversation because
taking possession of your own body
avoids most of the questions i'm going
to be bringing up
in this video i just wanted to give it a
token acknowledgement because it's
this weird little subcategory and i
noticed it was a thing and it was taking
up space in my brain and i will not have
the only brain cells wasted on this
thing
gosh darn it but when body swap plot
lines occur
they are nearly always without the
consent of those who trade bodies and
it's
almost always an accident of some kind
when it isn't accidental
then the person who caused it is always
either a villain
or someone trying to teach the
characters who swap some kind of lesson
but accidental is by far the most common
so let's start there given the
involuntary nature
there's actually an initial innocence to
it because the people involved didn't
mean for this to happen so at the very
least they are not responsible for the
circumstances
how badly things go off the rails after
that
is going to vary on a case-by-case basis
ultimately the big issue at play
when talking about ethical ramifications
of body swap
is that of losing your bodily autonomy
someone is doing things with your body
that you cannot prevent
and have no say over but of course it's
probably not realistic for swappies to
just stay in one place
and do nothing and hope it fixes itself
if nothing else they usually have to try
and reverse what happens so
obviously things are going to occur with
your body
that you aren't in control of pretty
much no matter what so
there's going to be kind of a low level
background radiation kind of creepy
and whether or not that level jumps up
over the baseline
it's gonna depend on what one character
does with the other's body
and whether or not it's something the
other is a aware of
and b would be okay with think of it
this way
if you lost consciousness for whatever
reason
there is probably a small number of
things you would be okay with people
doing to your body such as say
safely carrying you to an unoccupied
bedroom if they thought you needed to
rest or taking you to a hospital
if it was more sudden and that list of
acceptable activities will probably be
longer or shorter depending on your
existing relationship
with whatever person is doing the thing
but regardless there's going to be a
considerably
longer list of things that you would not
be okay with
happening to your body while you're not
in the driver's seat guys dream about
this sort of thing
i'll tell you one thing crichton if i
find you've been dreaming anything else
to my body
i'll break your legs even if they are
mine
so the question becomes what do people
get up to while in the other's body
oh and before anyone makes an argument
along the lines of well and a swap they
both have control over the other so
doesn't that you know kind of balance
out
no no no it doesn't that's just
that's just the body swap equivalent of
mutually assured destruction it'd be
like two people borrowing each other's
cars the fact that you could
theoretically crash the other person's
car if they end up crashing yours
wouldn't actually make either of those
events okay
so when it comes to what another person
gets up to
in your body the elephant in the room
is going to be the fact that they have
full and unfettered access to your junk
and that's the kind of thing that these
stories tend to just
gloss right over which is probably for
the best because acknowledging that
tends to just bring attention to it and
annoyingly most of the time when these
stories
do that in some way and draw attention
to it
it's an attempted comedy which just
shows a
lack of tact and self-awareness
obviously somebody groping your bits for
their own enjoyment
really isn't okay now look we can make
allowances for basics like washing going
to the bathroom
but even those basics can get muddied if
there's a clear intent
to take advantage hey
i can look at myself naked then
there's the issue of engaging in sexual
activity with another person which
brings us neatly back to wonder woman
1984.
one of the big questions and one of
which i tackled in a way
coming out of that film was whether or
not diana committed
rape by being sexually intimate with
steve while he was in that borrowed body
if we step out of that specific example
we actually find that the issue can even
be bigger than that because it involved
a third party in addition to the body
swap people
if someone gets intimate while body
swapped then it's arguable that whoever
they are getting it on with
is not having sex with who they think
they are
because yes rape by deception is
in fact a thing this is an issue rarely
broached with any seriousness and the
prime example that i could think that
really touched on it at all
kind of botched it like really bad and
that was the episode of buffy the
vampire slayer from season four
when faith still definitely a villain at
that point in time
forcibly swapped bodies with buffy and
then
among other things had sex with buffy's
boyfriend
and looking back on it now i find it
more than slightly alarming that the big
issue coming out of that
was that buffy felt hurt because riley
didn't realize it wasn't really her
there is literally zero discussion about
the violation of riley
and going back to rewatch it's it's
actually kind of startling
but while sexual contact and conduct
might be
the most in your face issue with body
swapping it's far from the only one i
mean
body swaps are a super common trope for
one-off episodes of
kids cartoons so you know that end of it
is usually not going to come up so what
else is there
well i mentioned endangerment earlier
which is another time where wonder woman
1984 serves up a case in point of the
problems
this man whose name is never learned by
the way and is only credited
somewhat creepily as handsome man didn't
consent to having his body taken into
dangerous situations and repeatedly
thrown into fights
so now imagine that instead of touching
your junk while you're unconscious
somebody's just repeatedly punching you
in the face so unless the activity has
been
agreed to by whoever's body this really
is what right
does someone have to put that body in
fiscal or even mortal danger
the main way this usually gets skirted
around is that the danger is the result
of pursuing the means to reverse the
swap
so less analogous to being punched in
the face full force and more akin to
you know being uh smacked on the cheek
hoping that you'll wake up
yes it's physical harm but it's in the
pursuit of a goal that the body's
original owner would
want then you know that takes the curse
off it a little bit
at least for most viewers but we're not
done yet
because there's issues of fraud and
defamation because somebody else running
around in your body can pull
all kinds of activities and easily ruin
your reputation with friends
family or co-workers so uh i'll have my
briefs on your desk by lunch
that puts my balls on your chin by
dinner that
right there is schedule for sexual
harassment
awesome usually if this comes up it's
played for comedy like
most other things with this trope and it
also tends to either get resolved
by correcting the issue or the
characters actually decide that the
consequences are in fact a good thing
which a bit like the endangerment angle
takes a as long as it's all okay in the
end we don't have to question the fact
about whether or not it should have
happened in the first place approach
this is again unsurprisingly at this
point
another thing that wonder woman 1984
opened the door to and then just didn't
deal with at all i swear i didn't intend
this to be a knock in that movie but it
turned out that way
but we get a sense that handsome man
did have a life of his own of some form
the question of
whether he has family or friends who
might be worried about him
or a job that he's supposed to be at or
anything like that is just
flat out never addressed seriously
wonder woman what the heck
when trying to figure out how so many
shows and movies got away with doing
body swap stories while rarely
addressing any of these issues i really
started to wonder why
wonder woman 1984 stepped in it so badly
well for one thing it's actually a trope
more commonly found in television than
film
and as noted nearly always employed
comedically being on television confined
to episodes
usually between 22 and 50 minutes long
means that there's far less screen time
spent on the body swap
and that gives audiences less time to
start asking questions
it's over too quick to start poking
holes in it
keeping a light comedic tone also helps
divert because if we're all just
laughing and having fun an audience is
going to be less inclined to apply real
world seriousness onto what they're
watching
which is why you'd be hard pressed to
find a body swap film
that isn't a comedy of some form
i genuinely think that these might be
the factors
as to why so many people were asking
these questions about wonder woman 1984
specifically because
that movie is two and a half hours long
and fairly serious in tone which means
viewers had more time to think about
what was going on
and more inclination to take it
seriously and apply these kinds of
questions to it
that thing was a mess i still enjoyed it
but jeez
before we wrap it up you may be
wondering has every single body swap
story just ignored these issues and
hoped audiences wouldn't notice has
there ever
been a body swap story that was at least
aware of the ethical issues inherent in
the trope
on some level well
it's time to bring in the boys from the
dwarf
red dwarf series 3 had an episode
fittingly titled body swap
where two of the league characters swap
bodies and the ethics of the situation
are actually at the core of how the
story plays out okay so for people not
acquainted with this show
what's wrong with you okay seriously
though
it's a future set space-bound sci-fi
comedy the two characters involved are
dave lister the last human being alive
arnold rimmer
a hologram of his dead bunkmate now
when he was alive rimmer was a fitter
man than lister is or
ever was lister needs to get in better
shape
and rimmer is bemoaning the fact that as
a hologram he can't feel or touch things
anymore
so they agree to a temporary swap with
the idea being that rimmer will get
lister's body into shape
and get the enjoyment of physical
sensations again and then they'll swap
back
so first off this episode does benefit
from the swap being
planned as opposed to an accident like
nearly every other body swap movie
or show ever but more vitally than that
the two
lay out a clear agreement as to what is
and is not allowed to happen to lister's
body while rimmer is in it
an agreement that remember immediately
breaks because the
joy of taste and touch being part of his
existence again sends him into a
hedonistic
bender something that the show even
while playing it off her laugh
makes immensely clear is wrong
rimmer is unquestionably the villain in
this scenario to the point that he
actually steals lester's body
and almost kills it a silly campy
british sci-fi sitcom
took more time and effort to examine the
ethics and frame the failure to live up
to those ethics
as a bad thing than a two and a half
hour movie funded by one of the biggest
entertainment entities in the world
smeg in hell so long story short
there are a ton of weird creepy and
sometimes criminal
implications when it comes to body swap
stories but since the premise is
inherently funny
most stories ignore all of them and get
away with it for being short or comical
or both
and honestly that may have been the most
entertaining thing for me to pick over
not the ethical conundrums of the
premise though i did have some fun with
that
but rather taking a look at why the heck
most stories seem to get away with it
despite these questions
because for all the times i've spent
talking about problematic tropes
representation and all that sort of
thing
there are ways to mitigate inherent
issues there are ways to present
these things that the audience is gently
directed away from the ideas that make
it uncomfortable
which is exactly what wonder woman 1984
failed to do
and sometimes you have to see something
drop the ball on a concept
this badly before it makes you
appreciate how
so many others actually make it work
i think that's about it starting to
wonder if i should check in on jessie
are you [ __ ] kidding me uh i'm sure
it's fine
thank you for watching if you like what
i do i have a patreon without the
support of which
i couldn't pay my bills and keep this
whole thing going and of course
i'd love to hear your comments about
this and the old staples of like
share and subscribe are a big help too
but you also don't have to do any of it
because at the end of the day you are
the council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned
um
bye